[Music]
our parents are older uh they're older
than us yeah and i guess they're
technically elderly isn't that weird
they're definitely elderly yeah but um
they don't act like it so they get a lot
of these awful like predatory
uh telemarketers calling them trying to
trick them into buying things or giving
away their credit card information and
uh grandma used to get a lot of those
and it drove me nuts it made me so mad
i'd relish answering one of those calls
because i used to love to do
keep them on the phone as long as
possible and and make them waste their
time you say it like it's a past tense
thing but you still do it yeah i know i
know i don't know why i said that so
they call and they'd be like uh yes we
wanna and i always click one i always
want to talk to somebody and they'd say
yes are you in the uh
if if you
don't want your life to be over you know
buy this credit get this credit card and
give me your oh and oh yes but i don't
want that to happen
well okay then give us your information
and uh what type of uh computer do you
currently use computer that's the thing
with that oh yes my grandson got me one
of those you know you i just play like i
smell a lot like an old lady that's a
really good old lady oh really boys i do
a pretty good old lady i bet you
convince them i do for as long and then
they find out you know because it just
becomes absurd and they'll say uh
sometimes i had one guy say
he said [ __ ] he said really they say
really awful things uh once the jig is
up and they realize they've wasted their
i think it's noble of you to do that to
protect our parents i would say the
problem with it is
you might be getting them on a
list that's like because then they go
into the category of oh if you call this
number they'll pick up i know instead of
they don't pick i i was correct in doing
the past tense because i did kind of
stop doing that because of that reason
well now you're a hero
and i you know i think sometimes about
like glenn garrick glen ross like i'm
they're on some list they're like the
glengarry leads they're like the coveted
lead though they're on yeah you're right
a list that people will answer i've read
the play i've never seen the movie oh we
gotta change that it's great i'm not
gonna shame you i'm excited for you i'm
excited for the show me too let's do it
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i hope
you're excited i'm your excited host
justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
and with me as always is my brother
christian who's never seen glenn gary
glenn ross but he read the play
um you know what it takes to suffer i
almost said i almost did isn't that a
funny way to be said that in a mocking
way yeah but he read the play but oh i
didn't mean that yeah i almost said uh
he thinks he's so smart he reads plays
yeah
anyway uh why are we talking about
glengarry glenn ross uh we because we're
talking about before that we were
talking about telemarketers yes and how
you still
apparently just stopped doing this bit
where you keep telling marketers on the
phone as long as you can yes yes uh and
i get very excited about what their
pitch oh that sounds lovely yes you know
what you've already explained i know but
you know what i i think i'm inspired by
is the granny
in tweetie sylvester and tweety remember
her voice oh yeah she you just sound
like her yes that great voice um you
might say that you like uh messing with
people joking with people yeah um and
sometimes it's not always a practical
thing to do like in this case it's i
would say it's impractical to be joking
with them because it might lead to bad
things i agree and today on the show on
life is short we have
one of the best
jokers in the world yeah on our show i
don't think it gets better they have
taken joking to an art form to an art
form i mean they've elevated it to a
thing of real beauty and
i've talked about this once on the show
i know that impractical jokers is a show
that i've
to say i i've discovered it or even fell
in love with it is kind of an
understatement during the pandemic it's
been um it's been a real uh
refuge i would say or it's been it's
been a source of so much joy and
escapist entertainment you like it like
okay yeah um so our guest i like it our
guest today is sal volcano who um is one
of the impractical jokers and for those
who haven't seen the show
um we should give it some context
because you talk we talk quite a bit
about it it's a show about four lifelong
friends who are from staten island i
believe yes joe murr quinn and our guest
today sal they've been friends since
they were in since high school yeah
and they've been a comedy team ever
since and for the last 10 years
they've had a show on true tv called
impractical jokers where
they um mess with each other where they
where they play tricks on each other and
they have to do things they have to do
dares basically yeah in public in front
of strangers yeah real world real life
um pranks basically where they have
they'll have an earpiece and the other
guys are feeding them lines their
challenges where they have to say
certain things to unsuspecting people in
a waiting room or in the park or in you
know these public spaces it's impossible
to do the show justice by talking about
it impossible to see it yeah we should
also mention that he has a podcast
that's very funny
he has two actually one is called taste
buds i haven't heard that one yet but
that's the concept i'm really into well
it's one that you wanted to do with our
friend james duffy at one point you you
guys had an idea about doing every
episode was about a different uh candy
right or something sweet something sweet
and we thought it would be a good
spin-off show of life is short called
life is sweet yeah yeah and i still like
the title i know and the concept but now
uh i feel like it's not original val's
doing it and he's doing it really well i
mean like he gets i would do well too no
i'm not saying that but he gets so
passionate i would get passionate too
taste buds that's a great name too great
name and his other one oh belongs
with the z
hip wayne spelled buds but um he also
did a uh he does another one with this
comedian krista stefano who's also
stefano
oh really i'm pretty sure stefano you're
right de stefano oh no i hope he's not
listening maybe he is chris i also know
chris
and uh well whatever so we'll just check
those out check those out but um more
importantly check out impractical jokers
if you haven't
and um i hope you enjoy this talk
with uh the uh
artists the
the the prank they're like what would
you say sellers um
he's he's a humorist he's a prank master
prankman pregnant brilliant prankman uh
and my friend and just uh one of the
funniest one of the you all you'll hear
salvacano from impractical jokers life
could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
people must think already like
regardless of how much you share people
must i feel like i know you so much
better we hung out a few times but like
i feel like since quarantine since i've
been watching so much the show
i feel like i know you so well now
really oh my god
you really probably do we heightened it
a little bit and you know we we're
playing for comedy and stuff but i mean
it's really that is just us and that is
like a blessing and a curse because
people are so loyal to us yeah because
of that sense of familiarity but in the
same exact respect
they are very they feel very familiar
with us
you know like there's no like barrier
between us
i'm really curious about this now that
you guys have been doing it for so long
it's been i mean not this is your ninth
season is it more difficult to
go out in public and and and prank
people and and yeah it's gotten
progressively difficult i mean for the
first season was a dream because nobody
knew who we were yeah yeah so there was
never any hold up and then
as it progressed it got more and more
but we've gotten so good at learning how
to do it efficiently and learning little
tricks that we have to kind of stack the
deck to make sure that we find out if
people know us or not oh my god
we started filming we got two episodes
in the can of episode nine before the
pandemic started and then we shut down
then it was like how in the world are we
gonna continue this show because
yeah yeah and you can't just roll the
dice with like anyone on the street
because of the disease so we had to get
all these protocols in place and we
ended up like
renting buildings or like college
campuses that have many different looks
and we get to set up shop in all
different stations in different
classrooms so everyone is separated you
know with the shields and the mass
everyone gets tested every single day
and we're just relegated now to bits
that are
focus groups uh presentations interviews
things like that where we have to book a
mark to come in got you but you've been
doing that stuff in the past it's not
like you've never done that yeah no
we're just leaning into it now yeah you
know they still think they're coming for
you know a presentation a photo whatever
it is so they're they're going through
the you know those motions anyway they
have to be tested so so as long as they
don't know who we are and how tricks
sorry so how do you how do you do that
how do you make sure they don't know who
you are how do you screen for that
for sure so the producers like um
they asked them like just a host of
questions like way too many than we need
of all different topics and then one of
the topics inevitably is about tv
watching habits um
what stations do you watch not even do
you watch the show because you don't
want to so they're not deliberate about
it they don't want to cue them into
right so this is the checklist if they
check true they're out you know what i
mean and then even before that when
those people then get to set
we have a lot of tricks so if they're
going to come in i'm doing a
presentation they'll be in a holding
area and like let's say like quinn will
also be in that holding area uh oh he'll
walk in like he's also taking it and if
there's any recognition yeah you can see
it right away i bet
yeah they well it's funny because
sometimes
they try to hide it but oh so insane
once they know it's impossible for them
to hide it yeah yeah yeah there was one
guy
with joe i think it was where you were
doing you were making them kiss
everybody which i love that bit where
you're just keeping just like kissing
people's heads
they're taking pictures in a grocery
store and there was one guy who
recognized him
who knew spotted him and you just kept
having him kiss him oh on the cheek do
you remember this over and over and the
guy was like are they telling you to do
this
yeah sometimes
if it plays out like yeah it plays out
there where we know we could wink and we
get to like sometimes we'll show that
because it is true like it's people's
number one question it's like everyone
knows you it's like it's really not true
we film in densely populated areas and
not everyone knows us i mean i don't
know i've never seen
game of thrones it's like the most
famous show of all time either cast
walked by me i i wouldn't know well you
were the cast you know like pete
dinklage probably
i do know pete yeah yeah but i think
that's probably it and that's only
because i was a fan of his prior but
other than that i i'm not and you might
say people that are on the show but i
also understand like not being not
having an awareness or an appreciation
for how big or how popular the show
might be because it looks like a small
you group that you shoot with it looks
like kind of a close-knit
little
crew
and and it's your buddies and so it's
like it probably doesn't seem like
that's a thing that a lot of people are
absorbing or or
digesting you know it it must be strange
it's amazing it actually um it's not
even just us it's like what's amazing is
like the crew that we've we started we
had like just a handful of people on the
crew yeah you know like we were doing
like uh
multitasking like i was doing everything
i was cold calling for locations oh
really
yeah like we didn't know how to make a
show like we you know we got we had some
failed pilots and things like that
because the guys and i uh met in high
school uh-huh
and so we've known each other 30 years
now we've been friends since high school
and you know we did like some sketch and
improv together in the past
comedy troupe called the tenderloins for
years as the so it was that core group
it was the four of you guys yeah it was
actually one other of our pals who his
life path went a different way very
successful in his own right and then
quinn used to guest like guests with us
and stuff we started in 99 then like
2003 or 3ish we had like performed so
much and we tried so many things and we
kind of took a little hiatus
and um and then but then in 2006
youtube came out and myspace came out
and so we started for the first time
filming sketches
and putting them online
we had not only done stage before that
were they at all
related to
pranks or pranking other people or were
they just pure skeletons oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah the idea for like the show
with hidden camera is strictly strictly
impractical jokers that was never our
thing it was never any involved in any
other project we had single camera
shows sitcoms of game shows we had you
know we did like improv straight sketch
and if this was just one
concept we had um that you pitched to
true tv yeah it was actually kind of
wild so so in 2006 we started uploading
these sketches online they were just
straight comedic sketches and um they
got some play on youtube and myspace and
and that got us like an agent and then
we got on a television show and it was
like a battle of these sketch uh sketch
teams from the united all across the
country
and we were one of the five finalists it
was like this big
uh glossy studio show huh and
yeah and and it never aired but we won
weird
and we won a hundred thousand dollars
just 2007
and they had to pay us by law so we like
won that money which was like to us in
two i mean it was like oh yeah it blew
our minds and then from there we got an
agent we started pitching shows and then
um yeah and we had a lot of failures but
this is the weird thing is that we set
up a round of like general meetings i
suppose with a handful of networks at
one point and we're like we don't want
to just go in without anything and we
didn't have anything so we were like
let's have lunch
and this the meetings were set already
true and mtv and a bunch of other places
i forget where and we didn't have the
meetings were set and we didn't have the
idea for practical jokers we went to
lunch
we went to lunch we thought of two or
three ideas and we said all right let's
try this hidden camera idea and then
that next night we went into new york
city with just the four of us with our
cell phones
and we taped
like four or five examples of us in
stores we hid and taped us just the four
of us on our selves cut that together
brought that in a few days later oh to
the meeting that was already scheduled
oh my god and they they they bought it
it was like it was like winning the
lottery i couldn't believe it oh my do
you remember what those that first thing
was in the store do you remember what uh
oh my god i do yeah because we because
in our first tour we're on our fifth
tour now we like have a stage show now
it's it's not anything yeah
yeah it's not anything like the show
it's like basically like stand-up
storytelling things like that but um
uh-huh in our first tour ever we showed
the the pitch tape so like oh oh it was
um it was so s it was much more simple
um we had to go into we went to times
square we went into like a
sephora or something in times square and
we had to
uh try to get uh products
but with speaking of made up language
like just just on the spot just make up
a language and try to get help through
the whole process so we did that then we
went to victoria's secret you have to
say everything in a different language
in that like one bit
oh like stephanie is just
exactly that yeah
exactly which you probably are good i
mean because you either got it with that
or you don't because if you just
hesitate one second and show that you're
not confident you're over
well that's why you're all so good at
this and they're different degrees if
you have different strengths but i i
would say like the the common thing you
you have that you're also good at is
that you're great on the spot i mean
you're just they're great acting
exercises where you have to um
it's improv but you're acting you're
acting with real people but it's still
pure acting skills i think you guys are
all so
you know which is why when you crack up
and you it's just uh
i think it's degrees of that and some of
you i think you're so good at it in
particular
especially having to come in oftentimes
you have to come you have to make
yourself likeable
so you don't turn somebody off right
away yeah that's that's the delicate
balance i mean look i've never had any
experiences you know when we're doing
the show
i know that we edited it i'm i'm in
there
directing myself almost editing
producing my head but i also have to
like we're making a show you know i'm
you know but i also the thing is like
the exercise is to also try and get rid
of all that and just approach every
single scenario
as myself that i was
you know 35 years before the show even
started because people need to connect
so i'm like yeah i know that i'm i'm
still nervous sometimes that's why it's
like the show i think still works we try
to evolve it and change the games and
push and change the scenarios and and
the things that make the like the
challenges like win or lose like the
parameters we try to keep mixing that up
but at the base of it is we still never
ever know on any given day how any
person that never met us before is going
to act and and exactly it's always
unpredictable so even though i got a
thicker skin
yeah element of surprise so you have to
really ground yourself in that before
you go into one of these scenes and just
really be yourself and react as
you really would you know like to these
people
sal have there been moments because i've
been watching episodes from all the
different years and and uh sometimes i
notice certain challenges that like
i i feel like you guys would all be a
lot more sensitive about now like you
know the way you speak to a woman for
example or like if you not wanting to
offend and and wanting to be a little
bit more delicate there are certain
things that what do you try to avoid do
do you try to consider that when you
create the um the challenges now i mean
are there things that like you would
have done a couple years ago that now
it's like
maybe we lay off that it's a great
question um so when we were conceived
conceiving the show we were like well
you know
how could there be laughter and comedy
in in in the
success and the failure right because
like i said we're going to make each
other do these things but if we don't
want to oh wait maybe we're on to
something because maybe we won't have to
do it and then we can make the failing
part of it funny and then all of a
sudden it's going to be funny no matter
what happens hopefully so that was like
what we were hoping to do and then of
course to concede is we absolutely don't
want to say these things
we know they're taboo we we know we're
embarrassed we know they you know
whether they were on the spectrum
whether they're just little like you
know breaches of social etiquette or
personal speech yeah but all the way to
hey that's not like everyone everyone
would would agree that that was like
kind of offensive a little bit those are
the things like that they usually tease
right before a commercial break there
are things that are like oh no there's
no way he's gonna be able to say that to
that person yeah yeah yeah but but i and
since you guys all know each other so
well i'm sure
you you play to each other's weaknesses
as it were yeah we we tried at the
beginning i mean now it's like i think
it's more of a free-for-all because it's
like now it's like we try not to be
redundant in how we
fail because it's easy to go to those
things because they're always fail-safes
because you'll never say something like
you know what i mean so we try to that's
why we try to switch up the game too so
it's not just i refuse to say that so i
lose now it's like don't laugh or who
you know we ask them to write on you
know you know what what they did what
what you know what product is more
competent or you know whatever whatever
it may be
when when you're saying the name when
you're when you're playing the
receptionist and you're saying the
ridiculous names yeah i feel like you
might be the worst at that are you the
worst at that game is that hardest yeah
i'm terrible anything anything that has
to do with like i i laugh i'm a laugher
by nature me too yeah jolly guy and i
laugh i'm a good laugher
i know that yeah if i if i'll ever i'll
ever um admit one thing about my own
self i do laugh
i actually tell them to cut laughter of
mine out a bit oh oh really yeah because
um it's it's true and it's real and so i
don't think about it when it happens but
when we're editing i just i'm like i i i
can't laugh this much
it's it's it's not it's obnoxious but
doesn't it give it away too sometimes
like when you're doing the focus groups
for example and you guys are having to
you know you're creating your ideal
society let's say and yeah
and you just start laughing you start
you can't get through without like
doesn't that give away doesn't that um
like lower the stakes for the other it
absolutely does and
it's amazing that you just said that so
so when i'm what i was really
referencing just now is when i'm behind
the scenes and like i'm just falling
down you know i have the mic
in scenes i try really really my hardest
because
the
i've learned that the formula is with
credibility
if i have credibility that will bring me
the comedy that i need because if people
take me seriously or they'll suspend
this belief or even i elicit some
confusion or bewilderment
um that's where the comedy is lying yeah
and the second i laugh and give them
permission to laugh i either it's a tell
that something's not as what it should
be or i take detention out of the room
or i give them permission to laugh at
everything and so then for the rest of
my interaction with them
that is going to be the tone of the
whole thing it won't have um you know it
won't have any surprises it'll just be
like we both agree this is just silly
it won't be it won't have as much story
potential because each of these sketches
is like a real story um
like when you're i forget what is you
guys are setting something up and
there's a girl with kind of purple hair
and there's it's the one where you jump
into a box
in the background and you're saying
things to her that um
it's amazing how you get away with
saying
offensive things because you have such a
likable
personality and and you're saying it in
such a non-threatening there's such a
charm about it but there are times where
i remember in that one in particular you
turn away and that's part of the fun is
the audience we get to see you
avoiding them seeing you laughing you
know yeah which is why joe is so good
too because joe just says these things
with so much confidence it's kind of an
authority i know i know it's amazing
that's his trick his trick is like
almost like an authoritative
yeah i'mma kill him with kindness like i
s i gotta soften everything as i deliver
it i look for him in the face
uh and i i almost like uh try to
ingratiate you know something yeah you
plead with them to like yeah yeah
accuse your sheets and then murray just
thinks he's he thinks he's just above it
all and smarter than everyone else but
um
but yeah no like you know we but that's
the whole basis is that like we're
saying by saying these things and
squeaking through them or refusing to
say them we're saying like hey of course
this is not okay you know what i mean
like yeah we don't think this is okay
we're just playing a little bit with
you know right with the levels of this
stuff that's all it is right so in the i
look back and it's funny you say both of
these things because when we first
started younger
learning it um easier to go for the
quicker joke we quickly realized hey
we can't go blue that much and we can't
go toilet humor that much it's
low-hanging fruit and we want to go for
more of a like just kind of a unique
kind of like a off a little off-center
kind of jokes like just these yeah
weird kind of things that interactions
like these that's what's great when you
play with the absurdity that that very
fine line between i think about this a
lot which is why i think i love the show
there's such a fine line in in society
we've all agreed on these certain rules
and if you just break some of those
rules some of those societal rules just
like a little bit you know like that
when mers trying to
pull check out who's who's wearing the
wig or like
simple and it becomes like oh that's
such a simple premise yeah oh those are
my favorites
but they're brilliant because they
because just to break that line a little
bit it shatters the societal agreement
that we have with people like you don't
touch a stranger's hair you just don't
touch hair of a stranger and this is
what we get really like um
like this this this year we tried to
lean into where we're at right now and
acknowledge like where we're at as a
society so we were doing zoom
like interviews we were like applying
for jobs and we just did this ridiculous
thing where we like the guys and i if i
was sitting at my desk with my laptop
the other guys were sitting right behind
this laptop staring at me like right
here
and i'm i'm interviewing for a job and
we're doing stuff like when joe was
going i put a bat on a fishing pole and
i just had a bat like flying through his
so this ridiculous silly like
oh it's you try to check every box like
physicality like so there's those things
but then there's these simple things
that i'll just like take that person's
cigarette out of their mouth and put it
out tell them smoking's bad you know or
oh man that's great yeah oh yeah or just
like um there was one we did that just
was called mind your manners and it just
was like going up to someone in the park
i'm like excuse me
stand up straight and it's just like
what
what did this person and it's those
little it's those little simple ones
yeah i love the most oh the park ones i
saw one recently where you said um you
had to say to i'm you have to apologize
to somebody
and um
and it's funny when because like you
said you never know who you're gonna get
and some people are
a lot more uh
willing to accept critique or you know
especially if it's done in a way that's
like sort of likable you know whatever
however accessible it is um but now
we're like now we'll like we'll make
reference to
also where we are now as a society as
far as that's a little more edgy now
we're waiting for someone to be like you
know nine years ago in episode 11 they
said something that and this is like but
we know that we don't want to say that
you know like we're
picking this up from a different handle
but now we'll even be like like we'll
even say we had a bit recently where
everything we said was well in this
climate like we don't want it like and
we just said you know we lean into it a
little bit you know what i mean
there are certain weaknesses that each
of you guys have that you all know so
well it's so fun to watch you explore
those like exploit those it is wild
what's even worse is when they go like a
little further and evolve
you know family or not even like
weaknesses like i won't say that but
like they know that i'm just uh i'm i'm
scared of cats i'm scared of like i mean
we've beat that heights heights you're
scared of heights we kind of did all
that and i like almost tell them
sometimes yeah guys please enough of
that like stop turning my family against
me but um yeah but
like they'll do like i'm truly i'm truly
scared of haunted houses like i just i
really am it's it's like i don't believe
that it's a monster or a ghost but i
cannot handle sudden jolts of like if
someone grabs my leg
so they put me in like
this old home and they locked me in
there and they made it a haunted home
and they put me in a cornfield and did
it once and i i end up getting a uh an
adrenaline migraine after those a
migraine because i am so like i just am
so adverse to something i'm an adult
but it's like they just kind of know and
you know but i had to play the sleeping
boy there it is embarrassing though
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
is there a part of you don't you think
while it's happening like i know they're
filming me i know nothing's gonna get me
is that comforting isn't that comforting
um
to an extent it's what i used to tell
myself when i was little was my it's a
trick my mom told me when i was
terrified of nightmare on elm street
and uh it was like two years when i was
a kid where i had to sleep with the
light on and the door open i have three
sisters one that is three years younger
than me she used to be on the bottom
bunk dana and um i used to we used to
have this deal and right before we went
to bed my mom would come and kiss us
both goodnight and walk out and i would
go
dana and she'd say yeah and i go will
you answer me
and she would then say yes i will and
that was us making a pact that if we
were terrified in the middle of the
night no matter if we were both sound
asleep and i was like dana i'm scared
she'd get up and she and and vice versa
but it was funny because my sister was
being vindictive we were fighting and we
went to bed at night and i go will you
answer me she's like i don't think i'm
gonna tonight like you know like she'd
really
turn the screws she withheld
safety my mom used to tell me just think
of like right when they're filming that
like right behind them is a crew and
cameras and like she's like
so like that's funny an age-old trick
but it doesn't really help yeah i just
saw i just happened to see a clip online
like someone posted a clip of that that
one that haunted house and the very
first thing that and i watched it uh and
i hadn't seen it in years i might not
have even seen it since i did it and and
i was shocked at myself at how terrified
that i got legitimately on screen as an
adult man from getting scared from a
child there was a kid in a nightgown
playing a piano in a dark candlelit room
and they said just it's terrifying go
get the candle it's in like this holder
and it was like behind the piano and i
walk in and i even say i go look i'm
gonna get this candle
isaac and then you can go on lunch and
your mom will drive you home you're a
child actress and i i
i i know i know that you got hired i
know that you need a lunch break there's
laws for children i'm going to grab this
candle i just say that and then i go to
the handle
and she's playing like one note like
she's just staring at me and then she
gets up and goes
and i i hadn't had the candle in my
hands i wish you could i wish i could
show you this
i screamed it it was like a scream queen
from the
the look of terror in my eyes i dropped
you're like
yes i dropped the candle the the candle
fell on the floor broke into pieces and
i ran out of room screaming
but it was an ugly face scream like i i
couldn't even control it it's so such an
ugly face scream because it's so genuine
and i was like actually embarrassed two
days ago while watching it i was like
that is too much
yeah it is
it's funny when you're doing something
you're in a moment i did this this show
with my brother called celebrity game
it's a just a a game show basically that
kevin hart hosts and one of the things
was this torque box we had to twerk i i
had to strap a box to my back with ping
pong balls in it and get them out of
this little hole we watched it last
night it was my dad's 82nd birthday and
and i looked over at one point and my
dad's watching and i could just say like
everything on his face said
i'm i'm he probably wasn't but it it
read like i'm so disappointed
they have my dad come on just to tell me
he's disappointed in me like ten zombies
oh
well you're that's the thing i wanna
talk about you bring it to your dad my
dad turned 75 five days ago actually so
oh happy birth
he's somebody i've never met again i
feel like i kind of know him but he is
he he seems like you guys seem so close
like your buddy like your friends oh
yeah yeah my dad it's amazing
relationships we have a real close
relationship it's like it's such it's
such a nice thing that i never
anticipated to have
um
him on the show and that kind of be a
thing that will live on like you know
it's just like though that yeah i have
that moment to look at it just it's
really funny he loves it you know like
he does oh he seems like he's very
comfortable on it yeah well yeah he's
he's the dad and and i the parents that
uh
the opposite of what i i want but i i
appreciate and understand it but they'll
be at like a restaurant and just like
you know unprovoked my dad would say
like the waiter like so uh what
television do you watch you know
oh my yeah yeah yeah
one time i was with my dad you must be
mortified when that happened one time um
i was with my dad he loves like the
attention um yes it's like nice in a
nice place of moderation for him i'm a
little bit like shy in private but we're
eating and um we're in this booth at a
diner and it was like a big family
behind us and uh that kids and family
they're like a whole bunch of them and
they peeked over and they saw it was me
you know and i was like oh hey guys you
know like nice to meet you whatever
and i was like thank you and i'm just
like eating and then at the end i went
to go like to the back to pay the bill
and i said all right i'll just just stay
here i'm going to pay the bill i'll come
right back i will leave and i'll and i
go and then when i come back he has two
of the children in his arms and they're
taking they're taking photos with him
because he's been on the show you know
so yeah
no thank you and like trying to keep my
head down yeah when i come back he's
doing a photo shoot
uh so you know you know the narrative is
now going to be like yeah sal was a
little standoffish his dad was great
though
yeah he got to he got to play my dad in
the movie in the movie we did oh i i
can't i haven't seen i will have seen it
by the time this yeah
it was it was funny it was it was doing
well then we got the pandemic it was
actually in theaters
that's right yeah but we had a really
good four weeks before that even stopped
so we did it did well but he played my
dad and you know we played our younger
selves
um just for a small portion of the
beginning where we met in high school
and so my dad flew out to atlanta and
he's we're staying in a farming together
and he had his own little name on the
trailer it was like oh
he must have loved it and he was super
nervous and um
you know you know i mean you know
there's like this whole crew and like
there's a video village and all eyes are
on him and like it mess up you start
over it's like so it's it's a lot of
pressure it's so funny to imagine you
guys out now because
yeah you like you're natural you strike
me as somebody who kind of shies away
from attention and
you know i know that that's not in your
nature um i want to talk about your
podcast that you're doing with uh not
chris that's not the one you do with
chris yeah so i just launched two uh
one's called taste buds and it's with
joe tate
um oh joe derose of course it's i've
just heard clip eclipse uh
and i've i've been following you guys on
on twitter it's really i love this
because my brother and i go through this
all the time we it's a show about snacks
where you're dissecting two different
snacks right yeah essentially like i
guess they taste snacks and review them
joe and i have
in our real relationships we have
blowout like drag out fights yeah over
like simple things and i'm like i'm so
tired of like
the politics and and all this stuff
going on right now in the news and i
need we need we want to do some escapist
so um we were like why don't we make
this into a podcast so what we do is
we'll pit just very simple things that
people are nostalgic or passionate for
like oreo vs chips ahoy doritos vs
combos mcdonald's versus wendy's just
things like that and it's short it's
like a 30-minute podcast we put out a
twitter poll at the beginning of it then
we argue it like it is like a the scene
from a few good men
yes yeah you get really heated yeah
yeah and then at the end we checked the
poll and see who won simple format easy
mindless it's just been fun and people
just go off because it's it's hard not
to listen because you everyone has an
opinion yeah yeah it's just kind of like
um so we like that that'll be fun and
then my buddy chris destefano
who i do the podcast hey babe with we
toured together for like two years and
we're on the road and like you know
spending like a week at like you know 20
weekends a month
a year with each other wow and it's like
we're telling stories we're always
laughing like we should just
turn this into something and you know
the quarantine was like we want a thing
that we can call our own have our own we
be creative connect with people so it
started up because of that uh and uh was
like this is the perfect time to start
we wanted to start it and that's the
perfect time what i love chris
what's what's the angle on the um the
hey babe uh podcast
so chris and i uh again it's like a
promise of nothing controversial
um but just stories and hot takes on
just fun simple silly stuff chris chris
is um very much like me in our like
comedic sensibilities yeah just like the
way that we deliver like totally
jokes and stuff we just kind of rant and
we're like it's like we're silly we're
just silly and like um i don't know i i
just want to quickly get back to you
talking about doing stand-up and i know
that's something you really you're so
good at it i i loved seeing you on
seth's show because you
you did a thing that i i find so much
comedic value in which is reading just
it wasn't like bits or um it wasn't like
jokes really you were just reading your
mom's text do you remember this
yeah yeah i actually do i i i um
yes seth is always like let's do
something just just for the show like
sometimes i'll go on and do just my
regular act but a lot of times says like
let's just let's do something
yeah else so i was like you know i was
like over i was
toying with the idea of um making a a
book about my my mom or my mom's texts
in general and then i was like then i
was like maybe it'll be a chapter and
something bigger but i had been
collecting them for quite some time
they're just great you know because they
come in all the time and then
do you have any now
there might be a folder on my phone
right now that says mom's text i just
remember laughing that's the first time
i'd seen you perform it was one of the
funniest you gotta love right i actually
found like oh great oh okay so i don't
know i i i don't know if they're collect
like um in order but i could give you a
sense of some of these yeah this is
sal's mom
one time she just texted me so what you
think
and i and i just was like
what are we talking about it was 7 05
a.m
she says so what do you think and i said
what are we talking about and she writes
my mom's 70. she writes mcgregor worked
worked hard in the beginning got tired
and then mayweather took over it was a
good fight
i was like what you watched mcgregor
versus mayweather when did you do this
and why are you texting me at 7am about
it
does she not watch boxing usually
no
i mean never not once in my life have i
ever discussed anything like that i
didn't know who she knew who those
people were
[Laughter]
that's crazy
she goes off on home shopping network
like i swear to god half the
conversations i have with my mom are
pleading pleading with her to return it
within the window of return time because
she she is a sucker for home shopping
network they could they could sell her a
pile of [ __ ]
can you see this she's like look what i
bought from home shopping network so i
have no clue have no clue what to do i
think it says something about an app and
she bought this whole entire virtual
reality
kit my mom
so she goes no i could do what to do i
think it said something about nap i said
you should have a really easy time with
this i couldn't stress
and
she wrote i'll bring this to your house
so you can help me um i go how much was
this and she says uh 129 95 plus tax and
i said
what are your intentions here
and she wrote back virtual reality
so then it's then it becomes incumbent
on you to go over and you got to do all
the technical stuff with her yeah and
then i found that at target for 28
dollars
i'm like i i sent her a screenshot and
here's a screenshot from target for what
what you bought for 28
you need to stop blindly purchasing
things and
being a perpetually uneducated consumer
mom
why hasn't she been on the show she's
been on um here and there
but um i mean i don't know if she's been
like
featured as much as my uh uh-huh but she
she she has been on she definitely has
nothing but you know what's weird i'm
trying to think is like we've been doing
the show right now for 10 years so it's
like i'm just trying to remember i can't
believe we've been doing it this long
but you know chris gethard
yes very funny yeah comedy
he's in yeah another another new york
comedian and jersey guy and just a good
friend of mine she texts me lol is
chris's last name
get hard really his last name
and i'm like yeah i was like of course
mom but it's pronounced it's not
pronounced get hard
it's pronounced gethard and she writes
oh
how many o's in that o
o h hhh oh okay
[Laughter]
does she do emojis does she has she
started doing emote
she did she's trying to do emojis um
she's she's insane but um
she always gives me the same ones it's
like the same exact i think she has them
like i think what she does is she opens
emojis and then it's like the five most
popular and she hits all five because
it's always like like praise
uh kiss heart yeah thumbs up
yeah it's the same exact one so i think
she just runs her thumb across the
bottom
yeah i got i got a flag from like
botswana from my dad i don't know what
it meant it was connected it was
connected to like
you know are you picking up groceries or
something botswana
um
i wonder this about a lot of the
sketches is
what do you do afterwards because i know
sometimes you show them sometimes like
that you do it behind the scenes where
you reveal
what the bit had been to the
unsuspecting uh participants yeah
do you always do that and and is there a
part of you that knows that that will
eventually happen so you have like an
out eventually
okay great question so um we decided
early we didn't really want to show the
reveal to the person
um because it's been done a lot in the
past that's actually like the hallmark
of
certain shows i think candid camera they
did it initially and what they did was
it failed at first candid camera because
people didn't think they had permission
to laugh this is old piping and old
thinking but back then the formula was
oh they're getting one over on these
people
i don't know how to feel about it then
they they tweaked it and they started
showing the reveal and then that like
let the person know oh my god this is
hysterical they're okay with it i'm okay
with it and then that that led to you
know the pioneers and that led to a lot
of other shows showing the reveals and i
actually thought the opposite i thought
we were trying to do something people
call the show a prank show i i and they
call it a reality show they like to put
it in a box
i i think it's um a hidden camera show
and just a show about friends really
that's kind of what i totally take from
it um prank is definitely the easiest
way to relay
the air of what's going on but we
actually
specifically don't use prank in our
vocabulary
we don't use it in the in an office in
the writers room it's and if and if
someone has an idea
we have all these little adages or
little little names we call them like
it's two prank sinatra it's too frank
can be like
yeah
but um yeah so we don't so we don't do
that um but um well we'll bleep out all
the times i've said prank during this
interview
but no that makes sense
because i think that's why i
love the show on a level that um
i've always enjoyed those types of shows
hitting camera prank shows but you're
right it's about the four of you i've
even when you're being like dicks to
each other there's so much affection in
it that's so powerful it's so fun to
watch
i i so much appreciate it um are there
ones that just go so south that you
can't air them
it it it's very very few and far between
yeah it's usually either
um we had them more in the beginning
we've learned a lot more how to elicit
and what to get out of what we need in
the beginning we were throwing a lot at
the wall
most most of it would either happen from
an ill-conceived bit
uh that just wasn't funny to begin with
like the first thing we ever can that
never showed was we were playing mimes
in central park
and um
it was just terrible it was just like a
crutch we had to put the paint on it was
a 90 95 degree day the pain was going
into our eyes our eyes were all
bloodshot we couldn't speak as mimes it
was like what are we doing
so that never aired and then another
time we decided to um go to a children's
park and what the idea was that we had
to
go up to
babies younger babies and baby talk to
them and then transition and have a
conversation with the parents while
we're still baby talking
they'll be like you know and what do you
do for work what do you do you know like
um it was silly it was just silly yeah
and um yeah we didn't realize that like
an investment broker that is so nice
yeah
we didn't have kids though so we went to
this park and we're walking around
approaching the children oh god
and um and they called the cops like
people called the cops
the cops came and broke that up do you
ever try to convince people who are
maybe on the fence about signing
signing off on some do you ever go up
and say hey will you you know explain
the show and
we have we do everything we can like
first we'll try to offer them a little
money then we'll say like you know we'll
explain then we'll say look you can have
you can see the cut give us your number
we'll call you we'll email you the thing
so you see because some people are like
what is this or am i being a made a
mockery will i be yeah at all yeah and
then sometimes they'll call us back out
but again it's like when i
they don't know me so like yes i'm the
guy that was in it and i'm the guy that
to them is gonna be like i'm the main
guy of the show but like i'm no one to
them so sometimes it doesn't do much
it's actually my most disliked
facet of doing the show is like coming
back out and being like please i bet i
dance i've had hat in hand
yeah yeah yeah we usually tell them hey
do you have any family members um like
you have a big you know call someone in
your family right now and they'll be so
happy that you're on the show hopefully
usually there's someone do you have you
know right any kids or whatever like you
know younger people maybe
and sometimes they do they'll just like
text someone and be like anyone over
here and then the people are just like
oh my god oh okay okay i'll you know
like yeah oh and so i'm sure that in its
success and the longer you've been doing
it that kind of scenario is probably
more common and gotten easier to get
this yeah
it's gotten a little easier yeah this
might be hard for you to answer but
where did your phobia of cats start can
you trace it back anywhere
i know exactly
oh really i had a friend my my buddy
steve um
he used to live
right like our uh like right down the
block for me growing up and i used to go
to his house he had this black cat named
sebastian that violently attacked me
anytime i walked into the home
i used to go i used to go into his house
through the basement door and his
basement had one of those half walls
so it's like in essence like um
people use
a built-in shelf like all around the
basement uh-huh you know what i mean so
it's like and the cat so the cat
could walk on that so the cat when the
door was open that thing was like like
five feet high so the cat was that face
oh it's like face level oh my god and i
used to walk in and you just swipe like
and claw my face and then
um
just you specifically or would do it to
everybody
i only remember me but like it is what
it is um but my sister i don't know if
you could tell on i have a scar right
here in my eye it's like a big red
scar and they actually photoshop it out
of press material sometimes because they
think i want that but i live with that
i've had it since like fourth grade my
sister hit me in the face
with um a malibu ken
and the hand like you know it like went
into
and i and i think um from there i had
this fear
and i also have very bad and i know
people say this but this is like
diagnosed so i've had this bad adhd and
with that comes ocd and i hate um when
anything pointy or sharp is near my face
or eyes
dude like to the point where like i want
to get like hypnotized because it's like
if um it's flaring up
i have to like if i'm it's crazy dude if
i'm in like laying down in bed or like
on the couch and i there are even things
on the shelf like book corners or
anything i get up and have to correct
every
single thing or even sometimes i don't
want to do it so i just i'll throw a
sheet over like the whole coffee table
or something no kidding
cats are just this wild card they don't
listen to you they have claws and teeth
and like they're always like freaking
out they just rub on you like there's no
person and then i think it's like i
don't know if it's snakes or cats but i
i feel like they sense my fear
and um i used to live i used to live in
this um this apartment that was down
like it was like a basin apartment so it
was in the back of this house so i had
to walk down the driveway and i lived
there for like 10 years and there were
neighborhood strays that used to just
sit dead center in the driveway and i'd
come home and park and then go to walk
down the driveway and they'd be there
and i'd just be like you know like
i i couldn't pass them and i'd be like
you know shoot shoot and they just they
knew i was scared they just they just
they just wouldn't leave you know so i
just don't i just collectively i've had
bad experiences with cats i just don't
yeah
so no problem kittens are no problem
[Music]
[Music]
so i'm taking advantage of your kindness
i just have a lightning round just very
quick questions uh and we're almost done
what is your most we're talking about
emojis or parents using them what is
your most commonly used emoji would you
say your go-to
absolutely i uh i was never an emoji guy
i actually have a bit about emojis how
we are reverting back to hieroglyphics
as a society that's funny i thought
about that yes
just very simple cave drawings
yeah it's like now like i mean you know
now a pile of [ __ ] is enough to send a
picture of a pile of [ __ ] that's going
to express your feelings
yeah yeah so and then i'd be like you
could you couldn't do that in person
like my bit is like you can't walk this
up to someone at the mall
launching into bits on pockets never
worked yeah well
well i i should probably um follow that
advice but my brother and i always find
it's not a bit but we just find it funny
those those memes we sometimes speak in
meme form so like we'll find ourselves
saying oh that feeling when you know but
it's like yeah or like or like mood you
know when you see somebody and it's like
that's a penguin that's like a penguin
who's getting towered over by a bigger
penguin
what mood is that how have you why can't
you just say what you're feeling
say the mood
right
that feeling when
i always forget wearing the keyboard so
now now my big one i use it i went from
you never using it i use i know the
clear cut one i use when you type yes
it's just a thumbs up and i know now
that you could hold the message and put
thumbs up but i just put that big orange
thumbs up hand yeah i just yeah i i just
use that one all the time it's so much
easier than that just exactly searching
for it a heart maybe a heart uh-huh it's
nice it just gives it's a little
send-off it's like the acknowledgement
love it it's kind of like a little
closing to the to the chat yeah yeah it
gives it a little uh like a tone it
gives it a little like warmth it it
lifts it up a little bit yeah i see i do
see the benefits at first i was like i
can't i'm an adult i might i can't stop
using emojis but like everybody uses
them some you know well you know what i
always i always felt um i always felt a
little self-conscious about using lol
oh yeah i don't do that one i i i write
out hahaha yes yes
but but ha ha is compensating for lol
but it's doing the same exact thing
anyway you know but lol is to me it i i
i know i'm analyzing it too much i'm
reading into it too much but it it's it
just sounds so phony because
i if you're laughing out
usually you write that you're not really
laughing out loud no it's a bit like if
it comes across a bit disingenuous yes
yeah lol if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play oh god
oh my god well
i was never much of an athlete i played
some sports as a kid like you know in
like like school i played like um in
grammar school like basketball baseball
terrible uh i played hockey in high
school and that was the most fun sport
i've ever played
so i think like i think hockey hockey is
so fast-paced and fun and everything so
so you can skate you wow well yes i i
well i could skate
i i was the best
i remember trying to skate again after
like
10 years of stopping my friend was like
let's go down to this parking lot and
pass a puck around and no joke i i was
like
skating around for 20 minutes and i
i i literally i don't know how or why
but i spit up blood
oh my god
this was 20 years ago
so so i was like yeah and then i
remember we went across the street and i
ate a steak sandwich on garlic bread and
a beer and we went to a bar and i just
stopped i was like this is not i
remember the day i remember what i ate
because i was like it was like i thought
i might try to play hockey again and i
quickly realized that i will never again
come back to sports if you could have
one snack food this is like uh taste
buds this would be a taste buds question
one snack food for the rest of your life
what is it
these are good i take these seriously i
know that's why it might not be a
lightning round question i gotta oh is
this lightning round i should have been
yes sorry you said that i should have
been like this this this okay no no i've
been talking around
okay yeah a specific brand
uh
tate's
oh tapes really so you prefer the hard
to the salt to the soft something
there's a crispy buttery crunch to taste
that i that i
daydream about
okay okay that's great um what is your
favorite movie sequel of all time your
favorite sequel
god this is so good uh
right out of my mouth it's either rocky
or back to the future i don't know oh oh
you
but you don't prefer back to the future
two to one do you
no
okay okay yeah but i don't it's a i
think it's like a really solid sequel
yeah germinator has a really solid
sequel godfather has a really solid
sequel yes um
yeah i'm trying to think of trilogy
indiana jones has a really solid sequel
oh i love temple doom yeah
have you been anything with sequels uh i
was the fourth die hard that was a
sequel
um
what else oh this at jeepers creepers
they made a sequel to that i had a
little thing in that kind of thing oh
but you win the sequel of cheaper
scriptures a little bit i i do a thing
where i gr the one of the characters the
cheerleader has a premonition and i warn
her about the creeper i worked like two
days on it
um
how i showed up filming like something
where you have to get murdered or like
uh it was they put a green screen on my
eyes okay uh
and they but they they had to shoot it i
had to dress up as the creeper
um in the original because at the end i
i there's a my body i don't know if you
remember the ending
my body is kind of hanging up and the
eyes are out
yeah it was it freaked me out yeah
you've done so much because what was it
husk tusk tusk yeah yeah yeah
you saw tusk yes yes yeah
it's funny
tusk was
hard to watch
yeah well it's funny we were talking
about parents like my mom
uh
like
like legitimately got upset with me for
doing that movie
i don't want as she go i never forget
she called me halfway through the movie
she left the theater to call me from the
lobby why did you do this really
disgusting and disturb oh and that man
she was talking about kevin smith he
knows this so i don't i i'm also
friendly with kevin oh are you okay
kevin's into the show he likes this yeah
i've known kevin for like brian quinn
hugh used to work with kevin uh for
viewer sku like 20 years ago so we've
known no kidding yeah we've known kevin
since like very early on yeah
well kevin loves this she goes
i don't want you anywhere near that man
i want you to stay away from that man
he's sick he's twisted um
what uh what's your go-to karaoke song
sal
oh my god this is so good um
i got to go with it's reigning men by
the weather girls
oh great
and i and i and i i know it because i
used to host karaoke not host but i i
held a karaoke night at one of my
neighborhood bars for a real long time
it was like crazy it was like this crazy
karaoke dance party fun where like
everybody came in costumes and would
jump around and people literally used to
swing literally swing from our rafters
during these parts oh my god well you
know that's what seth herzog does he's
got that great party that new year's
party at sid golds yes i love it i've
been to the halloween i haven't been to
a new year's it's i'm always with family
but i'm surprised i haven't seen him he
throws a mean party too you're right who
was your first celebrity crush i uh
probably um alyssa milano oh yeah she's
great yeah growing pains alyssa milano
back in that day it was like alyssa
milano when i was younger cindy crawford
nicole eggert remembered that
yes she was one of my crushes she's not
everywhere that's right
yeah i know yeah yeah nicole eggert i
could go on i mean yeah what unique
taste
yeah
if you had a tattoo uh do you have a
tattoo
yes i actually it's funny you say that
because i i didn't know how many i had
and a couple days ago so like i was
talking i was like let me i have seven
oh that's right yeah you have a few well
what's wild is i have um i have personal
tattoos mostly but i have two tattoos on
me on both of my thighs that i had to
get um for the show for the show and the
movie
oh my god so so this so if you didn't
see this app um
we
everyone lost butt joe
joe was gonna give us all tattoos the
caveat was we weren't allowed to know
what they were until they were done
oh my god so we were allowed to pick the
location but not know what so oh my god
you gotta go
back a calf that's a smart location i
went i went side side thigh
uh-huh
because that's i mean back of calf i
have other ones but people aside thai i
thought had the most limited exposure
yeah yeah so to murray goes and he peels
it off and it was a he looks like a
ferret we used to say he looks like a
ferret and um
he he we threw him out of a plane and he
cried all the way down we called it cry
diving so we did he got a he got a
ferret
a ferret skydiving right which is kind
of like a fun little yeah
yeah
and it's also because of a reason it is
and it's so it's not that embarrassing
it has to do with a personal thing and
something that happened in his life yeah
so that so hugh goes and he gets he
loves cats q has three or four four cats
and q gets a picture of a cat a
cartoonish cat and it says this was six
years ago at this point but it says 38
lives alone has three cats
but q like loves that about himself so
again yeah yeah you know it's fine and
then i go and i peel off my thigh and it
is a
an authentic
realistic portrait of a 15 year old
jaden smith
it is like a beautiful oil painting
portrait of jaden smith
nothing
nothing to do with me
nothing at all to do with me
and i just was in shock because i was
like is this jaden smith and he goes
yeah and i go what does this have to do
with anything and he goes nothing and i
my face i was like i actually said i
think i said like
this one is gonna this one's gonna
affect the friendship
it is
and um
and dude i so i live with this i live
with this oh
my god yeah my my uh my girlfriend
didn't like it because like it's weird
and like then i of course i also forget
about it because like and then like i'm
gonna get in the shower and i look like
oh my god i have this thing you know
and then like if i ever get like a
massage like one time i got a massage oh
my god i was like i forget you know and
then i was like 45 minutes through it
and the lady i was like face down and i
heard like the lady like i heard like
and then um
right by my ear she leaned forward and i
heard her go
will smith
she said will smith and then i was like
i just like i was like i gotta just look
back and i go
of course not i go that would be
ridiculous
and i go
it's his son
right now
but
in the movie um
we go to we go to a movie premiere of
jayden i didn't know this and they make
me go and like there's a q a and i'm in
the crowd going i'm your biggest fan
jaden jayden i don't know jaden was in
on it he calls me up on stage
okay and the guys are like i was wearing
daisy dukes and they like show them
europe since i've shown the tattoo and
the crowds going nuts like some people
might know me but a lot of people don't
yeah and they were just like what is
going on this adult man has a tattoo of
this so uh jaden on stage goes well i
don't even look like that anymore i'm 21
now um
we should update it
oh no and then in the moment in the
movie we leave his movie premiere go to
a tattoo parlor and he poses for a 21
year old full-color accurate portrait on
my other thigh
no
all right let me do this for you let me
do this let me see please
so this is can you see
uh yeah yeah yeah oh my god wait
can you see that
[Applause]
i live with that
he'll say like are you gonna remove it
and i'm like it's not in the sphere of
the show but i really want to remove it
it's like you can't it's so good there's
seven and a half billion people on this
planet nobody has a six to 15 year old
and a 20 year old jaden smith on their
thoughts yeah
it's uh even like hardcore jaden smith
fans
you know they don't
he was so cool he was very nice about it
uh
i didn't i didn't know him when i got
the first one and then we we
met him afterward and he was uh he was
really happy
we watched the show at home with my
family and stuff and and then we asked
him to do it and and and he to his
credit he was like he did it he was
really nice he lent us his time
wow
stood there and and
he was in the tattoo parlor as i was
getting it
but the second one must have been a lot
easier knowing that you already had
you know it was it was um
it was hard
yeah
five or six hours um
and uh
and then you know
it's with me every day it's it's it's
it's funny what uh what's your favorite
fruit
orange
orange
well you know what it was orange was my
whole life growing up but now i'm
getting older and it's too acidic
you know when a blueberries oh a cherry
oh got a good cherry yeah
good cherry a nice ripe cherry goddamn
so good i was pounding those i i i could
eat the whole just they're just so
delicious because cherry came on late in
life for me but i'm teaming up with some
cherry cherry see the seedless ones the
the kind of orangey ones those yellow
ones you know those are good but i
prefer the pit i prefer them oh yeah
yeah i don't know there's something
about the
experience the ritual i like yes yes
like it's the reason i love a pistachio
you know i i like a little bit of work
you know it's a little my brother will
love the technique you could apply a
technique to the way you you would
consume a cherry i'm into it uh-huh yeah
um
uh who do you want to who would you want
to play you in your in your biopic
in the sal volcano story
this is a good um
uh i don't know man anyone who is uh how
about you
you'd have to pack along a few pounds
but
i'd be honored
uh i would be honored to play you i i
think it'd be
um i feel like i could play just because
i feel like i know you well enough to
maybe take a shot at it
that's that's amazing like if you had to
play me i i don't even want like how do
you even do i
i don't get that concept like you know
how do you that's another thing when
people play these
these biopics like it's like yeah no you
can't do an impression
and right it's always fascinating to me
how how do you get to make it your own i
know of someone and and it's your own
yeah i know i know um
uh who's your favorite simpsons
character
uh
i i a ashamed i'm ashamed to say that i
am not a huge simpsons guy oh yeah no
kidding just funny cell it used to be we
just changed that question it used to be
who who's your favorite muppet
oh are you more of a muppet that's
probably ralph
oh yeah animal animal you know uh-huh
but now you know what fozzie i mean i
love the muppets
yeah yeah yeah too okay yeah it changes
but simpsons i mean like i watched it
when it first came out you know what it
was about me too yeah like a season or
two but uh i definitely haven't seen it
in a while
it just feels daunting to try to start
it you know because it's like yeah 25
seasons or whatever yes yes
um who do uh what do you prefer i know
this one this is easy dogs or cats
obviously dogs but do you have any dogs
no but i hope i hope to get ones uh i
plan on getting one i'm i'm in the
process of maybe moving and waiting
until i get to like the new place and
then i'm going to buy oh cool i'm going
to get a dog adopt probably but um yeah
dogs all the way i've had him in my life
i've had him in my life but uh nothing
recently joe has
eight dogs
what yeah he does he does um he rescues
dog he's a big like uh adopt uh advocate
oh my god he has eight and like he buys
them as seniors and likes half of them
are blind and then they just pass and he
just gets enough he just did i swear to
god every time i talk to him and every
single one of them is named after a
pastry it's pretty funny
that's funny oh that's right he's always
shoving pastries and
the amount he eats is incredible
uh the beetles are the rolling stones oh
my god are you kidding me stuff sorry i
love the beatles but i like the rolling
stones a little a little better i mean
yeah yeah the beatles have more
concentrated hits in relation to their
body of work
yeah the rolling stones have a lot of
hits but they also have a lot of knots
but um
have you seen them in concert i think
that's part of it too i love the stone
stones in concert uh three times and
i've seen paul mccartney once um and
they were both
absolutely amazing i you know it's it's
both it's just that the stones resonated
with me a little more when i was in
college i think than the people so
would you watch seinfeld or friends
props to both but seinfeld is probably
one of my biggest influences
uh yeah i can see yeah so i thought i
was addicted like i used to record them
on tape and then in a marble notebook in
a marble notebook i would just keep a
log of what's on what tape before they
uh you know had it before streaming and
something that's i could watch
yeah what would you i mean this might be
too hard but your
it's just the episode that you would
recommend if so if no one's ever seen
seinfeld i would say start from the
beginning but like if somebody wanted if
if they were like i don't know about
seinfeld what's the episode that you
would point to and say okay watch this
one
oh man my favorite it probably wouldn't
be good for a beginner but some of my
favorites are ones that are like these
like little one-offs like i love the one
where
george and jerry uh take a limo from the
airport that's not intended for them
for the nazi dylan murphy and colin
o'brien yeah yes yeah and i thought you
said you're murphy and you're obright
yeah yeah yeah and then it's like
they're attending to get to the garden
for the knicks game and it's like
there's just so many gems in an episode
where it's like we're going to miss the
tip off and the guy's like you think
someone's been tipped off you know
yes you know like and then it's like you
said about
that there were like classic plays
there's something very like um yeah
that seinfeld had a lot of that you know
it was like yeah it had a lot of that
like you know that
that that cadence of playing off each
other almost like a the rhythms on first
but like yeah those rhythms like yeah
yeah totally what is the one adjective
you'd want people to use to describe you
after you you've you've left after you
you've shuffled off
this mortal coil
what do you hope people if you could
pick a word for people to describe you
yeah i think about this a lot actually
that's funny that you said that uh i'm
sorry to make it morbid no no not at all
i i actually i had this i'm not kidding
you i'm not telling you i had this
conversation last night
literally i i couldn't be more and um i
yeah this is it's gonna sound like i
have nothing it's funny to say i i guess
generous
um or empathetic i i you know like
that's
you and katie couric
is that what she what do you mean that's
exactly what she said she said generous
yeah yeah yeah um
that's funny i mean i i hope hysterical
but i just mean like i hope
it's you know more more of my character
she said that too
he's like falling to the walls funny
[Laughter]
fearless with two jaden smith tattoos
um
uh thanks pal i i you you have been so
generous and um again like thank you for
all the the great laughs that you you've
supplied over the last few months a time
where i've needed to laugh you know
we've all needed to laugh so
thanks for them you're absolutely too
kind i gotta when you tell me it's
actually like it's very humbling man i i
i coming from you and
and just to just how he's just send me
such nice words all the time and i'm
always taken taken back by it i really
take it to heart i appreciate it oh
thanks buddy sorry it took so long i
just lie i love talking to you this is
so funny
anytime i'll do it again i loved it
so
that happened
yeah what a great he's got a great
accent and it's uh
every word there's certain words that
like
uh
he was in a diner and um what's the
difference between a long island accent
and uh staten island access i don't know
if i could i don't know if i know i
don't they are staten island right yeah
well long island is more is more like
this right yes
there's something we went over there
with the thing there's something about
staten island that sal's got a very
thick accent but i don't know i don't
know enough about
i love it i mean i love hearing him talk
and there's certain words that just uh
it's it's also very uh italian it sounds
very like italian new york
specific to that um
whatever it is it's great it's great
yeah and he's
so funny and like
happy doesn't he so happy
like like you really enjoy his life you
would said affable but that is such an
understatement it is affable for sure
for sure he's he's uh but there's i know
you mean there's a stronger word for it
there's like a there's like a zeal a
kind of like you know he's a zeal for
life he does yeah and a zeal and a zest
and a real um like he's so very
thoughtful mm-hmm i meant she's like
kind yeah when i mentioned
um you know celebrating the the point of
what i was saying wasn't that it was
possibility's second birthday was like i
bet i wonder if people think that's
funny i bet they do they call it their
dad paw little house on the prairie well
when i'm talking to you i call him pogba
because that's what we used to that's
what we call him but when i'm talking to
anybody else about him my dad my dad me
too i say the [ __ ] always sounds a
little weird to me you don't have to
call your dad your dad when you don't
call him that to his face but paul is
more familiar to you uh yeah he said you
know he said oh wish your dad your dad
happy birthday to your dad he's just
such a nice side he's a nice guy also
his relationship with his own dad on
that show is amazing it's amazing i
really like i think our relationship
with our dad's amazing but i can't say
that because that sounds braggy but uh
his i really like his relationship with
me too and the dad on the show is really
uh fun he seems like a it's like when
you see him on the show is one of those
parents where you immediately get why
cell is as affable and great as he is
yeah that show is and they all can tease
each other too which is the thing that
like you know yeah well that's just
about to say the great thing about that
show is that it's both
super funny
and there's real heart to it because yes
these four guys who clearly love each
other yeah make each other's lives
miserable
but it's done with so much love that it
never feels mean-spirited or i know it's
happy you know what i mean like of
course that combination is i know very
unique i know and it's the it's the
reason don rickles was uh
not just funny but like
brilliant i mean like he's the guy that
you want him to be your grandfather like
i remember just the way he'd insult you
and because it comes from it's clear
that i and i you can't explain why it's
clear but it just is it's just like
there's a there's an affection
underneath their teasing and even when
they're
you know putting each other in like
really uncomfortable situations and like
there are times when i'm like oh my god
i couldn't do that i fancy myself like
pretty daring when it comes to that
stuff or i used to be uh but there's
stuff that they they make each other do
that i'm like oh that you can't do how
is he gonna do that like i'm thinking of
especially the punishments that's what
i'm thinking of like the one we saw the
other night he makes
sal who you've just heard you know you
can hear what a nice person he is and
like compassionate about others and they
all are but like sal especially as i
they made him go to a um a poetry class
and it's a real poetry class that was
amazing and he had to
critique he had to kind of [ __ ] on some
of these these people get up very
vulnerable get up and read their poems
and he had to say things like
you're very good at uh you're very good
uh poet but obviously not a good
performer but a great poet like yeah
stuff like criticism that's not helpful
yes yes yeah so just for a little
context you guys spoke about it a little
bit but for those who haven't seen it on
the show they
give each other these dares like we were
saying and the the the one of them that
loses who gets the most you know
uh
thumbs downs at the end has it it's um
has to
have a punishment yeah that's what they
call it like and it's like so it's one
person having to do something
really uncomfortable while the other
three
laugh and feed them stuff to stay so
sometimes it behooves them to do uh to
do well yes exactly to like say whatever
they're being told to say and like some
they range from
really embarrassing like the poetry one
or like the um oh when sal had to
pretend to be a really bad stand-up
comedian he's doing a real stand-up gig
but he's got to be really unfunny and
for a guy like sal where like laughter
is who is the stand-up community exactly
it goes against every one of his natural
instincts and um but it's just
incredible to watch i was just about to
compliment you for not um saying it
chris farleying him too much and i just
did it but you love the show so i
understand
oh yeah i think michelle might have cut
some of my chris farley stuff out oh
really i did it a bunch
yeah in fact i was like you remember the
one yeah and he's been doing the show
for so long he struggled to remember
some of those things no i know like
there's so much fresher in your mind
than his and and he'd be like oh oh that
one yeah yeah yeah it was still fun to
hear the bts
the behind the scenes for a fan of the
show it was fun to hear how they do
certain things i know um but i i
realized there's something inherently
strange about the fact that he's on this
show ostensibly promoting himself and
and what he does but yet that the whole
his whole brand that whole show
only works if people don't know who they
are
so there's something very weird
about that i know well he talked about
that over the years as they've become
more popular
uh they've had to find ways around that
and one of them is to do
uh they they have some way of like
screening the the people the
unsuspecting they ask them like what
type of shows exactly yeah by season 35
they're only going to be able to do it
with like
feral recluses
yeah like everyone's going to know or in
like north korea
that'd be dark yeah but you know funny
uh yeah i know
but um i'm surprised and like but like
look at us i consider us
fairly um aware people of like
funny things and funny shows funny
movies we didn't know and up until
we got our finger on the pulse
until seven or eight months ago i
i wouldn't have known them that's true i
only would have known yeah that's true i
would have known the name but that's it
yeah i like i wonder if like i was in
i was one of their marks if i was like
in a supermarket when they were playing
throwing frozen peas across an aisle at
each other like i wonder if i'd
catch i would imagine i'd catch on right
away it depends where you are i think if
you're in new york
you might not think it's a bit because
there are weird weird things happen
that's true in a place like new york
city compared to the suburbs that's true
so you might just think it's oh these
are just like people you're right you're
right in new york yeah that's true those
guys must be um
like really intelligent about human
behavior generally general human
behavior now
because in order to he's talking about a
little step ahead yeah you need to know
how to read someone really quickly and
speak to them in a way that's going to
be effective for whatever bit you're
doing
so
they must be
brilliant at
cue especially people and like
categorizing different types of people
yeah i think so uh that tattoo story is
so funny god i remember thinking like
because sometimes i think about that
tattoo question it's like it's right i
couldn't ask jane goodall we'll never
have a better answer than that by the
way i
i swear to god that's what i thought
like that you could retire that question
julian jayden smith at two different
ages i tell that story i tell that
second hand to people and i get a huge
laugh you were laughing so hard
i i had i thought
if a person laughs that hard once a year
i know that's good like
they're healthy they have like a healthy
amount of laughter you know so then what
you say then so i think i mean this is
also easy for me to say it's not my
tattoo but i think then that makes the
tattoo worth it that it brings that much
he's really easy for me exactly i know i
know but he's got to live with it but i
still think it's the net benefit of that
the joy he's bringing to people yes with
those tattoos is also the story i i also
think it's just my value system but i
think like of a story that to me a good
story
trumps almost everything see the more i
think about it the more i
think that having two of those tattoos
is better than one because if it's oh
yeah you said yeah but i i'm changing my
mind you said it was just like better if
it's one because then it could just be
like well it's random and if it's just
one it
i think it's creepier
and potentially creepier and people
being freaked out by it but if it's two
then it seems like more of an obvious
joke in some way that's true the joke
itself would be would not be clear to
anybody unless they knew who he was
but it's more clearly
funny and it's whereas one is like maybe
he's just a huge fan and and it's more
of a complete story you know right it's
a better complete story it's like if
you're gonna go and get have one a 15
year old you might as well like and
you've already done it and it's like
complete make it like a richer
story with a resolution of course as a
story it's much better but i'm saying
just visually yeah i think it's it's
better it's better to have two because
it looks clearly silly yeah whereas one
looks like this guy might just be the
biggest jaden smith fan in the world t
like teenager teenage [ __ ] right also
like yeah i know you know maybe naughty
maybe maybe inappropriate yeah yes i
love that story told when he's getting
massage and she goes will smith
this is like this is if i only knew this
about sal i would love him he'd be one
of my favorite people if i only knew
that
sliced this vince likes this and that
his instinct was to lean into it instead
of being embarrassed and be like because
i would think most people would be like
uh yeah i get that it was a dare and i'm
sorry
that's a long story it's a long story i
don't want to get into i'm getting a
massage but that he
i love this about him that he said um
no that would be ridiculous
it's his son it's a teenage son and
commit he commits to it that's the other
thing those guys have to commit and when
they laugh when they like laugh during
the thing it um it kind of ruins their
cover god i love that show me too let's
read a letter okay
behind you in our printer
all right this is a letter from jessica
martin
subject six foot shorty in training whoa
hi justin and christian i'm a newbie and
just started listening to some of the
shows here and here and there sorry
and not here and there
while working from home i've gone back
to the bill nye episode and listened to
his thoughts on the chrono virus when it
first started oh yeah remember i mean he
was like that was the first couple days
of it interesting timing in retrospect
yeah that he a year later it was a year
ago wow back to jessica and listen to
his thoughts on the coronavirus when it
first started and he seemed very
nonchalant about it yeah he was for me i
think i've been cautious and even
cancelled a free weekend stay in arizona
in december 2020. wow keep in mind i
live in the cold of wisconsin all winter
long trust me that was a very hard
decision to do
now that it's been a year i've been
curious to hear his thoughts now of what
he thinks about it and what precautions
to take even now a year later and his
thoughts on the vaccine i would too wish
we could i wish we had access to him i
wish you just text him yeah but he's not
uh a friend guy
he's an acquaintance guy that's true
that's true
i just convinced my mother-in-law who is
over 65 and watches my 19-month old son
every wednesday to get the vaccine after
she convinced herself she didn't need it
because she thinks she's healthy and not
a high risk
your thoughts on meeting friends and
travel in 2021 now as well
do you plan to get vaccinated
and just because you guys love would you
rathers here's one for you okay before
we do that we should answer thoughts on
meeting friends and travel
um i've been slowly dipping my toes back
into traveling it's because it's been
for work uh we're traveling for a very
fun
now we can say family feud mm-hmm we're
doing the feud um so we have to get
tested technically work yeah it is yeah
it's work for charity our charity by the
way uh if you'd like to support and
check it out it's the hole in the wall
camp in ashford connecticut they
suffered a really unfortunate fire there
so wonderful charity wonderful charity
trying to get that camp up and running
for this summer but yeah they're testing
us and we're able to kind of do it
safely and everyone's wearing a mask
christian i'd
help me out with this computer computer
this commercial computer commercial i
did a couple of weeks ago and same thing
i mean testing so yes we're doing travel
for that
i feel like everyone's getting a little
better at testing and and
masks all the masks and stuff so yeah
i've i've gotten a little more
comfortable with it um we do i plan to
get vaccinated i do too we're in
connecticut so i think i think we're
eligible pretty soon in a you know in a
week or something can't wait but also
you know um
we're not going to tell anyone that they
have to get vaccinated no it's uh your
choice your body is your choice yes i
feel the same way about other things
your body your choice um but yes i am
looking forward to getting vaccinated i
would say
i would encourage the way jessica did
with her mother
i would encourage people to um only
because it makes it safe for everyone
else but like encouraging is different
than telling telling and shaming people
for not exactly um okay and then she
says and just because you would love
would you rather here's one for you
great would you rather
not be able to speak or speak every
language but no one can understand you
wait
say again
not be able to speak at all or speak
every language but no one can understand
what good is speaking a language if no
one can understand you
um i'll tell you what's good about it
uh
think about it um
i would definitely pick the second one
because you could say something but no
one can understand you but you could
understand
all these like all these languages yeah
that's just so you could travel
that's true yeah for sure that you're
right and you get to um
experience speak even if no one can
understand you there's something about
uh making these sounds that i think
people need to do yeah not talking we've
talked about this before on the show not
talking at all
for even a day is
really really difficult
you could also talk to yourself exactly
yeah
huh that's a good one but yeah
definitely the speak every language no
one can understand you it would be
frustrating to
be able to speak every other language
very and have no one understand you yeah
it must be very frustrating yeah i was
always jealous of c-3po because he could
speak over six million forms of
communication
that was the nerdiest thing you've said
so far today oh oh really yeah yeah i
guess it was
um hopefully it'll be the nerdiest for
the full day for the for maybe for a
month the day's young you never know
that's true
um
now i'm trying to think of something to
top that
anyway um i'll put that in i'll put that
in the back of my that feather in my you
know that in the back what's the
expression for i'll put that in the back
of my mind and
put that put that on the back burner
i'll throw that in the trunk
okay thanks and then back to jessica she
says it's almost over the rest of the
letter is just uh which i was going to
say to her her the rest of hers is
thanks jessica martin oh and i'm saying
right back at you jessica thanks thanks
jessica martin yeah um
and uh
thanks for listening yeah thanks for
listening and also uh a hearty thanks to
wasn't he like he was great he's great
and i just uh i miss i'd like to hang
out with those guys too me too and i
also feel like they're like they seem
like really good hangs let me ask you do
you think you could hang out with them
and not kind of be i'm asking myself
this to be like fanny around them like a
fanny
is that the nerdiest thing
no weird though yeah and a fan like too
much of a fan around them like gosh can
i or can you those are
very different you could i know i
definitely could you could you could too
but it would be harder for you much
harder who would be the hardest person
for you to hang out with and not fanboy
out
fan girl
no one would be hard christopher reeve
no no one would be hard i'm not saying i
don't admire a lot of people michael
jordan
i wouldn't want him to i know
some like eager annoying i would play
cool with all those people
if anything i would over compensate with
someone that i really liked
like jerry seinfeld you're right i
wouldn't talk about seinfeld
so intimidating
yeah i would i'm most likely to fan girl
out over someone that i have like
pretty lukewarm feelings over like um
uh wayne crabette
former wide receiver of the new york
jets yeah what's you what would you say
to wayne somebody who might want to hear
a compliment i'd probably ask him some
football questions i might pick his
brain about playing for the jets what
would you say to jerry seinfeld like hey
it's nice to meet you you want to be
that exuberant i would just be polite
you have you have i would be polite and
and i would try to be as affable as
possible you wouldn't pay him respects
and like you have 30 seconds to meet him
oh i'm not having a dinner with him no
no you're just like someone introduces
you he's about to go somewhere it's like
in passing oh i would i would uh
some version of
uh nice to meet you uh i'm such a huge
fan what if you were in an elevator with
him it was just the two of you and you
had like 60 floors to go up 60 floors
it's just the two of us yeah
um would you do it i wouldn't say
anything to him you wouldn't no
you wouldn't not because i don't respect
him but you're gonna try to make a joke
you must be sick of that people trying
to be funny i had dinner
right next to bill maher in la
number of years ago
and i'm a big fan
and i was sort of tempted to say
something but i
stopped myself because i realized
that's only going to be for me
he doesn't need me to say i like him
you're right that's a good instinct i'm
just going to interrupt his dinner
that's a good instinct so that's how i
feel in general about yeah celebrities i
do too especially people i respect you
don't bother to not want to bother
celebrities
that's good that's true have you ever
heard this when you've been around well
who cares um okay well no i'm curious
well when you've been around somebody
with like step like kind of famous or
whatever yeah have you heard people near
them kind of like performance like
performing
yeah yeah sure i love that like
performing fun or like being a little
extra loud yes i sure have yeah anyway
anyway um thanks again to jessica and if
you guys would like to write into the
show
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com and thanks again to
the impractical joker genius genius cell
balcony
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced and co-hosted by you
christian long and megan monaco senior
producer is michelle
whoa no audio engineer is a man whose
parents named him sergio enriquez
executive producer marshall lewis
exactly
wondering
the show
is shocking he's gonna go eat a sandwich
i can't wait low blood sugar maybe you
guys want to know what i'm eating
[Music]
you must hate cheesecake hate it
well it's just such a like
such an offensive combination i cake and
cheese you know what it is i yeah
for a long time and a few years ago i
gave it another chance and i really
enjoyed it because the cheese was so
mild tasting it wasn't like che as
cheesy as i remember oh wait it was just
like creamy and tasty
i guess if it adds i know the ideas are
supposed to add a little creaminess to
it and now they're cheesy exactly you
don't really taste the cheese maybe you
had bad but
i see my associations with cheese or so
it can be so like
but it doesn't taste like that kind of
cheese that's silly it's like cannolis
can be salty like cheese do it does it
can only taste like cheese it's kind of
the same amount
it's the same kind of flavor as a
cheesecake and
psychologically
i
i
i don't know if i taste a little cheese
but i think cheese when i eat it yeah
it's a real hang up about it mm-hmm but
i bet i bet like eggplant or something
something you've given it you've since
given a chance
mushroom cake yeah well
but like yeah like brussels sprouts or
something that you used to do i did use
a hay brush and now you really like you
gave it a chance and all it takes is one
good experience now yeah
french onion
per that's the example i'm trying to
think of thank you french onion soup
you